what's up does he have to loom like that  module Shelley that's a nice ride I mean  you can roll right at the Buckingham the  hell isn't that thing okay you American  man  shut it what am I doing here  yeah why is she here introductions miss  Vivian Wembley massive history Oxford  Doctor of Philosophy also Oxford and  dose of letters again Alex what I think  anything else anyway  meet Kate Yeager Cade Yeager I'm an  inventor oh you're an inventor yes I am  what have you invented a lot of things  Mike  like a lot of things like things that  you've heard of like well things that  you will have heard of okay patents are  pending yeah ah don't say what's up you  know I could do that - oh I'm English  and I'm too cool for villains what I'm  now I've come here to be insulted by  some overeducated IV towel princess  you